no I'm just kidding I love both of you
all right thanks Sean I am Laurie Ingram
this is Ingram angle from Washington
tonight The New Normal it strikes again
that's the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
now remember what the anti-trump forces
promised us in 2020 if Democrats won
things would go back to regular order
the country would be more united things
would go back to normal they want to
calm things down they want somebody who
can work across the aisle they're
exhausted by Donald Trump's chaos and
irresponsibility but Americans want to
get back to normal they want there to be
safety they yeah because you're normal
all right well let's just go through the
how normal things are today cocaine
found in the White House
only a few days after the Secret Service
bombshell the media was already
declaring that it's unlikely that we'll
ever know whose cocaine it was
but if some old lady wearing a Maga
sweatshirt walks into the capitol
Uninvited we know that you're going to
use every resource in the federal
government to find her after all they
left no stone unturned when it came to
January 6th these two gentlemen just
showed up I thought they were the
building inspectors I've just felt
violated by the FBI and they asked me if
I was there and they we want to show you
this picture is this year and I was like
no it's not me and I wasn't there
that's despicable also on their normal
checklist our treasury secretary
literally bowing to a Communist
dictatorship nothing out of the ordinary
there
is it just me doesn't she remind you of
that old plastic bird in science
experiments in elementary school my
parents never got me that but that was
kind of the cool thing and our esteemed
Secretary of State Anthony blinken his
thank you sir may I have another moves
are apparently very normal too
as I've said we are not about decoupling
we're about de-risking and diversifying
power behind the puppet the
then firm John Kerry it is totally
normal that he would have the most
influence of anyone in the
administration
man he's giddy about his upcoming
travels ready to do the full monty on
climate issues
at this point Kerry should be up for
some sort of Lifetime Achievement Award
for helping the CCP
it is imperative that China and the
United States
find a way to cooperate with respect to
the climate crisis by cooperating we can
accelerate the transition we can reduce
the emissions
this is all normal
and certainly we know it's normal that
the president and his family get rich
because of his official position now
let's not forget what Hunter is quoted
as saying and that what's at message
the Biden's the best that I know at
doing exactly what the chairman wants
but no matter the evidence no matter the
Whistleblower testimony the Press does
not give a rip
it's based on a WhatsApp we don't know
the verification of that we don't know
whether Hunter was exaggerating I I read
that statement and I find it to be
awfully flimsy on which to build any
sort of an investigation oh do you honey
well now substitute Don Jr for Hunter
with the same set of facts they could be
trying to validate you know the WhatsApp
message
now and speaking of inconvenient facts
the fact that our border is totally open
for cartels and human traffickers to
exploit well the Biden Coalition wants
you to think it's a-okay what's uh the
definition of secure border to you
it is in the context in which we are
working it is maximizing the resources
that we have available to us to deliver
the most effective results
and from crossing the border to
cross-dressing we all know it's totally
normal for men to pretend to be women
and perform in front of children
meanwhile the Biden Administration wants
America to think it's normal to turn our
military into a hostile work environment
for any Christian Muslim or Jewish
person who believes in traditional
teachings on sexuality
the open inclusion of Americans like me
combat ready transgender volunteers
enhances our Readiness promotes
Innovation and fosters a culture of
respect and understanding that makes the
Armed Forces better
nothing personal but most Americans of
course including most new immigrants
disagree
now I wonder how much that day-long
Pride Extravaganza cost the white house
and who paid for it well not the bidens
but relax it's all normal
look things are so bad that students who
merely use the phrase biological man and
referring to a trans person are being
graded down in colleges now later in the
show we're going to talk to one student
who was punished for stating the truth
yeah the truth is dangerous to the
regime it's so dangerous that they
believe it's not just normal but it's
necessary to gut-free speech to stay in
power
a Washington peace from Saturday bemoans
the recent Federal Court ruling that
forbids the feds from collaborating with
social media companies social media
injunction unravels plans to protect
2024 elections
now I still remember when liberals used
to be suspicious of big corporations and
big government working hand in glove
but now the regime is so petrified
because as we approach the critical
election Americans may actually be able
to communicate with each other huh very
threatening
The Ugly Truth is the left believes that
Free Speech only exists for them for
anyone else it's dangerous dangerous for
democracy
remember how enraged they were to cover
Trump and just a casual moment last
month as we watch Donald Trump attempt
to turn his arrest and indictment into
some sort of campaign commercial the
folks in the control room I don't need
to see any more of that
now do you really think those same
people are going to want to see Trump or
DeSantis on stage debating Biden
now when the US government is pushing a
radical agenda let's face it it's
totally normal it's democracy in action
but when the government truly represent
the people and their preferences it's
Fringe and it's fascist
he is a fascist a person with fascist
Tendencies because the GOP as we've
talked about George is a fascist
movement he's a white nationalist he's a
fascist he's embraced violence
and finally endless Wars have become a
Mainstay of the regime they're not just
endless by the way they apparently are
unwinnable as we saw in Iraq and
Afghanistan and sadly as we may see in
Ukraine as well
yet we're supposed to believe that it's
totally normal for us to spend what 200
billion dollars and counting on a war to
protect the borders of another country a
non-nato country as our own border is
wide open
so what the angle has laid out open
borders endless Wars a lower standard of
living deviant sexual indoctrination
it's not a byproduct of the regime's
agenda it is their agenda
they use open borders to hold down wages
and change the makeup of America they
engage with China as they are to keep
Wall Street and their donors happy which
then offshores jobs and hurts our
workers
they push for Endless Wars that are
enormously expensive and that we don't
win and then of course they use climate
change to lower standard of living as
well and fight against any emissions
that we put into the atmosphere
but they totally ignore the biggest
emitter of greenhouse gases in the world
China
you know this is their plan because if
it wasn't well they'd alter their course
but how many liberals for instance are
really upset that California and New
York you know liberal Utopias they're
losing population
Democrats love the results so much that
they even hope that look gavinomics goes
National soon
president Newsom
going on the road to take the fight to
states where freedom is most under
attack we have a lot of work to do to
build a movement to counter what's
happening in red States across this
country
in 2016 the American people voted for
Trump because they were tired of
government of the elites by the elites
and for the elites that haven't had
enough of norms of the Norms of Clinton
Bush and Obama and they chose a
different path
it of course to the left it was a
nightmare the fact that Americans were
becoming more independent and that
America was standing up for itself again
that terrified them so much so that they
decided to do the ultimate Norm busting
and use the doj the FBI and fisa to try
to destroy Donald Trump
if the country really wants to get back
to a healthy normal
we must refuse to allow the left to
mainstream Decline deviancy and
Corruption and that's the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else